the northern hog sucker you see this no
have you ever seen the northern odd
sucker I was enjoying your your high
school experience no no let's change it
up real quick you just gotta watch this
oh oh yeah yeah I have seen this and
I've seen yeah
yeah if you're listening on audio
it's a fish
[Laughter]
with the inside of a vagina like if
you've ever um
if you ever pulled back uh um Nature's
blanket
Nature's Hood
and uh you look just directly
directly
into the fun part
it's like it's that
on a fish you know the the guy holding
it is he's thinking about it every dude
20 to 27 had the same commentary on this
yo where's that food yo what lake is
that
why do I want to go fishing all of a
sudden
are you thinking what I think yeah
yeah that's just every yo I'm a [__]
that [__] bro
oh God I'm gonna put my penis in a [__]
they go what they they do it
bro you're great
don't wait my fishing pole teleported
why does this sound like that when they
close on your penis
it's too wild
you guys watching this you don't be sad
as helping you're digging a fish and
it's just like
it doesn't like gag or anything it's
just like
perfect yeah Jesus yeah
yeah no this is a good idea
[Laughter]
you know we're supposed to play it
no you put it in and it just slips off
hey
yo did you just slip out of the fish
it's all right man it's all right to
Graphics that lamb it's got me all
horned up that's what it did you know
what they say the the
fastest way to your heart through your
stomach yeah yeah
I would say so anyways racism if your
dick's long enough you can get through
the stomach to the heart
dick all in your heart dick all in your
heart
dick in your aorta
dick in your aorta I've never heard that
what is that Kevin Gates dick all in
your stomach oh yeah yeah yeah okay okay
okay
I'm supposed to [__] my live stream are
you gonna watch it
I think I'll be in Canada oh for real on
tour again I don't know oh God please no
stop Cody and I have to go to this um
like Tech conference thing for real yeah
we have to speak no for real actually
what the hell yeah I know talk about
what I don't know man hacking
is is you guys gonna be serious
yeah
I do not have the skill set for Defcon